tout est dans le symbole face distille à
la déshumanisation subi des sacs de
s'agacer des bidons représentant le prix
élevé de l'essence jeter pour salir ma
lancée pour rappeler l'immobilisme des
autorités une manifestation qui se
déroulait sans incident jusqu'à ce que
deux hommes franchissent les barrières
leur arrestation a fait monter la
tension d'un cran des gaz lacrymogènes
qui provoque la colère des manifestants
ne pas blesser personne
hanif lalani famine au cenou moment nous
avons noté que l'année passée à terme
nakba inégalités cabinet olivier
bérisson a appelé au calme calme qui est
revenu lui qui avait également appelé
via les réseaux sociaux avenue à
participer à ce qu'on voit
environ 70 personnes avaient fait le
déplacement
toute la population de gaza
couillet donc je suis large
solidairement avec toute cette
population
il faut dire en plaine où est la vérité
de la martinique
il faut commenter ni qu'il y ait un
contre-pouvoir les réalités les jeux
doit de connaître liberté nous nous
voyons prison égalité nouvelles
inégalités justice nous voyons et
justice en permanence et nous évitons
les autorités françaises a retrouvé peu
d'humanité ce ne sont pas leurs noix qui
fond d'humanité sur la bosse
le boost n'a pas besoin de loi on ne
peut pas laisser descendants arrivés
comme centre pas augmenter le prix de
l'essence et du gaz comme ça souffle
tout était symbole dès le début de
l'après midi ce convoi avait commencé
avec la protection des ancêtres